第10，我要讲的是，就是说你们两口子用你们夫妻共同财产给孩子买了套房，然后你们两口子可能是觉得怕房价跌呀，可能是觉得，呃，生意上需要钱啊，你们两口子又把人家未成年孩子这套房给卖了，你两口子卖了吧，如果有一方想要反悔，然后说哎呀，卖孩子的房子损害了孩子的利益，卖孩子的房子没有征求孩子的意见，所以这个卖卖孩子的房子的行为是无效的，那不行，你们两口子。
用共同财产给未成年买的房，你们两口子一起把这房给卖了，卖了就是卖了，你不能再以别的理由哈，说不能卖未成年孩子的房子啊，不能怎么怎么样，没有尊重未成年的意思，然后你说这个卖房子的行为无效，有些父母他原因是什么？就是卖了之后他觉得房价又涨了，他后悔，他想去说我这这房子啊就是无效的，卖了就是无效的，他想要想想要反悔，你知道吧，那就反不了悔了，明白吗？
首先这个房子是你们两口子共同财产买的，买在未成年子女名下的，其次，你们两口子共同去把这个房子卖了的，这个反悔不了啊。但如果说这房子是人家孩子从爷爷奶奶那儿继承来的，你们两口子是不能为你们的利益去卖孩子的房产的，因为这个房产是孩子从爷爷奶奶那儿继承来的，那就是孩子的财产，你们只有一种情况下可以卖孩子的房产，什么情况下为孩子的利益，比如说孩子要留学，比如说孩子要治什么什么重大疾病，为了孩子的利益，你可以卖孩子的房，如果说不是为了孩子的利益，你们两口子想要分钱，你们两口子想要做买卖，做生意，你们两口子想要还债，你们卖孩子的房子，这个在法律上是。
不允许的，就是卖孩子的财产，只能是为了孩子本身的利益才能这么干，这条对于要抚养费的姐妹们啊，对于要抚养费的姐妹们兄弟们就影响很重大，我跟大家讲一下啊，就离婚协议中关于一方直接抚养未成年子女或者不能独立生活的成年子女，另一方不负担抚养费的约定，注意啊，就你俩离婚了，离婚的时候，当时你说你不要抚养费，你就想要孩子，你不要抚养费你就想要孩子，好孩子归你了，你没有要这个抚养费。
那么这个协议本身对你们两口子之间是有效的，但是如果离完婚了之后，你这一头出现收入显著降低，比如说被裁员了。
或者说被调岗了，原来你一个月工资1万，你能养得起，现在你一个月工资5000，你养不起了，你还房贷，你孩子学费什么的，你养不起了，在这种情况下，你能不能再去问，当初虽然说说好了我不要抚养费，但是我现在我的收入显著的降低了，或者孩子的支出显著的增长了，孩子他可能出现什么状况，他的医疗费各种费用显著的增长了，你确实负担不了，你有没有这个机会再问对方去要点钱去要这个抚养费呢？有没有我问一下大家，咱普通老百姓就得从情理上来考虑，虽然当时没有要这个抚养费，虽然当时白纸黑字写了我不要你给抚养费，但现在我真的是没办法，我真的是收入显著降低了，或者孩子他真的是医疗啊，各方面的收，呃，这个需求增加了，我没有这个能力去维持孩子的这个现状了，我能不能去要这个抚养费，能这个情况下谁去要呢？就是以未成年子女或者不能独立生活的成年子女，以他的名义去请求，请求对方给支付抚养费，人民法院可以支持啊，予以支持，当然人民法院他支持的时候，他肯定得综合考虑一下你们离婚协议的整体的约定，子女的实际需要，另一方的负担能力，当地的生活水平，来确定这个抚养费的数额。
但这条呢，就是有一个风险，有一个风险是什么啊，就如果人家在离婚的时候，人家要孩子的抚养权，人家说不要你给一分钱抚养费，你心里也得有个谱，虽然说他现在嘴上说他不要你给一分钱抚养费，但是你还是存在着这种风险，将来他的收入显著降低，或者孩子的支出显著有所增增长，就甭管你是哪一头，我都给你讲透了啊。还有一点大家要特别注意的，就是比如说你啊，你在离婚的时候，你说我一分钱抚养费都不要，你就打着这个想法说我现在我就不要，哎，我过两年了之后我再要，我过两年了之后，我就说我生活困难，我就说我收入降低了，我就再去要抚养费，你打着这样的主意啊，你也得悠着点儿，为什么呢？因为对方有可能就基于这一条，你现在说你收入降低了是吧，你现在说你没有能力了是吧，那我就要求变更孩子的抚养权，你自己说的，你现在收入降低了，你现在这个抚养能力变弱了，你自己说的，那我就可以以这个借口，你这个理由，我就要求变更孩子的抚养权了。
大家理解这个逻辑吗？就是说任何事情他都有一个双刃剑，就你当初你你想要孩子，你说你一分钱抚养费都不用给，我就要孩子，我就要孩子，我不要你给抚养费，但是你又打着这样的那小心思，你说我过两年了之后，我再问你要，你如果过两年了之后，你再问人家要的话，那人家可能就会以你的抚养能力不足啊，你的抚养能力不行啊，以这个为理由，他有可能变更孩子的抚养权。第17条讲的是如果你不直接抚养子女的一方，没有按照离婚协议的约定或者其他方式做出承诺，给的这个抚养费，说白了就是本来当时你俩离婚的时候，约定一个月给3000块钱，但你一直不给，在这种情况下，未成年的子女或者不不能独立生活的成年子女，请求你按照当时的约定支付抚养费的，那没跑。
啊，请求你支付抚养费的没跑啊，以前啊，如果这个孩子已经成年了，那么孩子再想去问，当时你承诺要给抚养费，一个月几千块钱，一个月几千块钱，孩子如果成年了，再想问问要这个钱就很难了。但是现在的司法解释是，如果孩子已经成年了，你去问当初离婚的时候，他答应一个月给多少钱，去问他要还可以要。
啊，这个是很大的利好啊，姐妹们啊，对于那些一个人拉扯孩子，对方当初承诺要给抚养费，一直没给一个人日子过得可苦的这些兄弟姐妹啊，你们这条司法解释生效了之后，就算孩子现在已经成年了，你们就可以去要当初的这些抚养费。
具体能要多少年呢，就按照以前啊，可能有那个诉讼时效的这么一个说法，可能只能要三年，但是现在这个司法解释，他没有强调这个诉讼时效这个事儿，没有强调诉讼时效这个事儿呢，在司法实践当中，你说你有没有可能孩子现在都已经成年了，但是对方就一直拖着没有给抚养费，我现在再去起诉，要求对方欠的这些抚养费依法给我呢，我认为是有这种可能性的。
大家拭目以待，看一下接下来要抚养费的这些案例，看一下这个要抚养费的能不能够把他拖了5年，拖了6年没给的这些抚养费，就算我孩子已经成年了，我现在可以去起诉你，要求你把这个抚养费依法给我，看法院能支持多少，他到底是支持三年啊，还是支持说他一直没给的，都能够追溯到他10年8年啊，我感觉是有这种可能性的啊，因为这个法条他没写吗？没有写那么明确了，说他支持要几年的啊，几年的没给他能要，最多能要几年，他没写，没写在现实生活中他就有空间，那对于那些一个人辛辛苦苦拉着孩子长大了，对方明明答应要给钱不给钱的，那我告诉你，这就是一个天大的利好。
就算孩子成年了，你作为夫妻的另外一方，你还可以去要他，就是把欠的这些抚养费一把结清啊，有可能加油加油啊，这是重大利好，重大利好。龙飞姐我希望看到的际像就是对那些本来答应要给抚养费的，以为孩子成年了就不用给这个钱了，以为高枕无忧了，那么现在的司法解释就告诉你们，做你的美梦去吧，做你的红楼美梦去吧，该给的钱还得给整的。我挺高兴，对方说没钱，现在赖你管他有钱没钱啊，现在法律赋予赋予了我们有这个资格去管你要以前的那种法律环境啊。
基本上就是孩子成年了之后，你再想要抚养费就很难了，成年了之后再想要抚养费很难了，那现在的司法解释明确告诉你了，成年了之后还能要以谁的名义要就以夫妻一方的名义要啊，我挺激动挺激动，我也老想着那些孩子抚养费都不愿意给的人，我给你们一个打击，我让你们知道，让你们知道谁的厉害。嘴八条这些事儿对于哪些人一定要竖着耳朵听啊，就是对于重组家庭、再婚家庭，双方都带着子女过来共同生活的家庭，一定要认真听啊。
以前的这个规定就是说重组家庭、再婚家庭，继父母和继子女之间的关系，如果说继子女是跟随继父母在一起共同生活，继父母对继子女也尽到了抚养教育的这样一个义务，那么继子女和继父母的关系就在法律上等同于亲生父母子女的关系，等同于亲生父母子女的关系，就意味着继子女对你有对吧继承的资格，对你也有赡养的义务，这个大家都知道对吧？那么现在呢，就明确说了，继子女和继父母想要形成这个抚养关系，那么要考虑什么呢？要考虑你们共同生活时间的长短，要考虑继父母是否进行了生活的照料，是否进行了家庭的教育的职责，是否承担了抚养费等等因素，要综合考虑这些因素，才能确定继父母和继子女之间是否形成了抚养教育的这个关系，是否形成了这个相当于亲生父母子女之间的这个关系，他考虑的因素就更多，除了考虑共同生活的时间，还得考虑你有没有真的照顾这个孩子，还得考虑你对这个孩子有没有进行教育，还得考虑你对这个孩子有没有付出真金白银的抚养费，都得考虑进去，其手消费是关键啊，就是说如果你俩本身就是重组家庭，本身重组家庭了之后。
你和继子女之间可能生活时间也挺长的啊，就5年8年的，呃，10年8年的生活时间也挺长的，你也尽到了这样一个抚养他，教育他，照顾他，经济上啊，抚养费你也尽到了这样的一个义务，那你们之间按照道理来说已经形成了继父母和继子女之间已经形成了这个抚养关系，按照道理来说，你俩应该是等于亲生的了，按照道理来说，他应该赡养你，对吧，他也有资格继承你的财产，但是如果你俩离婚了，你俩本来就重组家庭，然后你俩又离婚了，又分开了，在这种情况下，人家可以去起诉，要求跟你断绝这个关系的。
就算你俩已经形成了抚养关系，就继继父母和继子女之间已经形成了抚养关系，人家你们离婚了之后，人家可以去可以起诉断绝这个关系，除非是什么呢？呃，除非是你们去办了正式的收养手续，你们办了正式的收养手续，他是没有办法断绝关系了，就啊没有办法，因为说离婚这个事儿断绝关系，呃，再有一个就是他离完婚了之后，他还跟随你生活，这种可能性比较小，哪有离婚了之后不随自己的生父母跟随继父母再继续生活的呢？很少，生活中很少，但是这也是一个例外，就是如如果出现你们已经去办了收养关系的，那么你俩在离婚也不影响你们和孩子之间的这个等同于亲生父母子女的关系，也不影响这一点，如果说你俩离婚了之后，这个继子女还跟随继父母在一起共同生活的，他也不能去要求断绝关系啊，接下来讲的就是说，呃，你俩离婚了之后，呃，缺乏劳动能力，又没有生活来源的继父母可以就是要求曾经受你抚养教育的成年继子女给你生活费，那么人民法院要综合考虑哪些情况呢？考虑你们当时抚养教育的情况，成年继子女的负担能力啊，然后依法可以支持你要一点生活费。
啊，但如果说你们作为继父母存在虐待和遗弃，虐待和遗弃继子女的情况的除外，这事儿说白了就是，嗯，你要是实在穷困潦倒，实在吃不上饭，实在揭不开锅，你问那个你拉扯长大的继子女去要点生活费啊，在继子女他有负担能力的情况下，在综合考虑你的当时为这个继子女抚养了多长时间呀，投入了多少啊，在综合考虑这些情况之后，适当的给你一点生活费，这么一个情况啊，30条讲的是什么意思呢？就是你俩离婚的时候，你俩说，呃，离婚协议白纸黑字写了，把这个财产给到子女，如果离婚之后，呃，这个比如说是房产吧，还没给子女当过户，如果离婚之后一方反悔了，想要撤销这个字，女的行为，那人民法院是不予支持的，但是如果你们俩夫妻一起反悔，就你们两口子都不想给子女了，那可以这这么个意思啊，就你俩在离婚协议的时候，本来我们就打个比方，本来是把这个房产要给孩子的，但是你俩离婚之后呢，这个房产一直没给孩子办过户，在这种情况下，如果一个人反悔不行，但如果两个人一起来反悔，说我俩不想把这个房产给孩子了，我俩再重新签一个协议，我俩重。
经分割这个房产可以，但如果说有一方不同意，另一方就可以要求继续履行，就继续履行，就继续给孩子办这个过户，如果实在办不了过户了，比如这个房子已经被对方偷偷卖掉了，那在这种情况下呢，可以要求分钱，要求赔偿损失啊。第二项是什么意思呢？就是说你们两口子在离婚的时候，你们约定把这个房子给孩子对不对？在这种情况下，孩子他自己是没有办法去起诉要这个房产的，除非你俩在离婚协议的时候白纸黑字写，孩子可以去主张这个权利，孩子可以去起诉要这个房产，跟你们两口子在离婚的时候商量把什么财产给到孩子，孩子本身他是没有这个资格去打这个官司，去要求你们按照这个协议走，但是如果你们的协议里面约定了孩子有这个权利，孩子有这个权利可以去打这个官司，可以去要求继续履行这个协议啊，继续给这个财产，那他就有这个权利，这么个情况啊，这一款讲的是什么意思呢？就是说呃，你俩离婚协议的时候，比如说把一部分财产或者全部的财产都给了子女了，但是离婚之后呢，你发现你是被欺骗的，被欺诈的，被胁迫的，请求撤销，人民法院是可以支持的。
啊呃，这个被欺骗被欺诈最典型的是什么呢？本来你俩离婚，你俩说把房子给孩子吧，你也同意，但离完婚之后，你发现孩子不是你的。
孩子不是你的，你就显然是被气炸了嘛，在这种情况下，你可不可以要求我撤销当时把房子给孩子的这个约定的，可以，这个说明白了啊，第21条就是说你们离婚的诉讼当中，如果有一方证明他在婚姻关系存续期间，他因为照顾孩子，照顾老人，协助你工作，支持你工作，他负担了较多的义务，那么在这种情况下的话，他可以要求给一个家务补偿，人民法院可以根据啊，就是你照顾孩子付出了多少，照顾老人付出了多少，你投入了多少时间精力啊，对对方啊，造成很大的什么影响啊，这个时候会考虑对方的负担能力，然后根据当地的人均可支配收入等因素，然后给一定的补偿，确定一定的份额，但这个补偿不会太多的，可能一年划下来就嗯几千块钱，按照以往我看到的案例的话，就一年划下来给你个几千块钱的补偿，能够给到1万的都挺挺少见。第22条是说离婚诉讼中，如果有一方他年老、残疾、重病等生活困难等情况，他生活困难，然后要求对方给一定的适当的帮助，就是说你们的财产正常分，分完了之后，你再要求再给你一定的额外的帮助，这个人民法院是可以结合另一方的财产状况给予适当的支持的，这个帮助呢也是呃，意思意思就。
年老了，有病了，残疾了，就是你们俩先分，比如说先公平的分财产，呃，一人假设分了55%，或者百分之五五六十，呃给弱势的一方，在这种情况下，其实你还可以要求对方给适当的帮助，是这么个情况，然后最后一条就是说这个司法解释什么时候生效，这个司法解释就是在2025年的2月1号已经正式生效了啊，然后这个司法解释今天用。
两个小时啊，从头到尾的给大家捋了一遍，有没有人是从头听到尾的，有从头听到尾的啊，真是对自己的权利，对自己的财产，对自己的人生负责任的一种体现，就是出现了新的规则，你甭只言片语的去看，网络上有很多比较极端的言论啊，可能会对大家会有一些片面的这个影响，你自己也抽个空，你把这个4000多字，婚姻家庭边的司法解释二，总共就4000多个字，大家可能半个钟一个钟就看完了，你自己去捋一遍，去看一遍，然后跟你息息相关的那些内容，你再重复几遍啊，多学习一下，这样的话，你才能够有力量去保护自己，因为我们自己始终是我们生命的第一责任人，我们不要寄希望于说父母能保我们一辈子，不要寄希望于伴侣能保护我们一辈子，不要寄希望于别人的良心会让我们一辈子能够过好日子，一定是我自己，是我生命的第一责任人，一旦发现跟我的利益息息相关的事情的时候，我要冲在前线，我要在第一线，我要搞明白这个事情，我要学会保护自己的武功，我要学会保护自己的方法，同意吗？